we've talked about ligo in many
different videos on this channel
including interviews with two of its
three Nobel prize winning leaders Ray
Weiss and Barry barish and I hope to get
Kip Thorne on for a new video sometime
soon so that's great have you learned
more from that than you could imagine
today we're going to talk about ligo not
as a detector of gravitational waves as
if that weren't great enough
we're going to talk about it as a way of
detecting dark matter
let's go
we're going to be discussing this paper
which describes Advanced ligo and Lisa a
future space-born version of ligo
as ways to detect dark matter by Evan
Hall and Nancy Agarwal this is looking
for what's called a scalar field
ultralight Dark Matter candidate
which have become popular we're
combining together two different great
Mysteries
very sensitive gravitational wave
detectors not used for gravitational
wave detection and exotic candidates for
dark matter the most mysterious form of
matter energy in our whole universe
makes up 80 percent of the matter in the
universe and yet we only know of one
possible candidate for dark matter and
that's the neutrino I've talked about
that in this video called Dark Matter
already detected but in that video I
explained that it's not possible for The
observed number of neutrinos and their
observed masses or the limits that we
have on their masses to account for the
amount of dark matter that there is in
the universe there either has to be
another form of dark matter or as we
discussed with Mordecai Milgram and with
Stacy McGaw there must be a modification
to the laws of gravity two different
completely bipolar opposites in terms of
explanations this experiment could get
down to the heart of what's called a
particulate candidate for dark matter so
a so-called scalar field described by
the mathematics shown here could account
for dark matter if there were sufficient
abundances of these dark matter scalar
fields to close the gap between the
ordinary matter like the kind that we're
comprised of baryonic matter and the
missing amount known as dark matter
these types of scalar Fields change
What's called the fine structure
constant which is the governing
parameter that controls the size and the
force of interactions between
electricity magnetism and what are
called photons the strength of
electromagnetism in quantum mechanics is
governed by the fine structure constant
the name finds structure dates to early
spectroscopists from the late 1800s
finding in the spectrum of glowing hot
hydrogen gas when observed that there
were strange lines that needed to be
accounted for these were later
discovered to be part of What's called
the program of quantum electrodynamics
by Richard Feynman and others who found
the solution for what the fine structure
constant was its value but we don't know
what it is why it is what it is in fact
it has the value at ordinary
circumstances of about one divided by
137 which leads many physicists to set
the number 137 as their combination on
their luggage logs for the TSA now if
there were a light scalar field it would
change the size of the atoms which is
parameterized by the same fine structure
constant and it would do so in a
periodic fashion in a way that ligo
could detect given its Exquisite
sensitivity to Tiny variations in the
size and scale of its cavities of its
laser lock cavities that we'll describe
in just a moment so you can measure the
frequency of a laser as it oscillates
inside of a solid and it would be
exquisitely sensitive to the change of
the atomic radius which would in then if
shown to be periodic varying
sinusoidally as shown in the first
equations that would be evidence for a
scalar field which could then have an
Associated Mass which could then
possibly account for the amount of dark
matter which we observe we don't observe
the Dark Matter itself but we observe
that there must be dark matter in the
universe
do this the scientists are using ligo
shown here
but not using ligo to detect
gravitational waves it's using the
phenomenal construction of what are
called the test masses and the lasers
cycling within it this is from the ligo
team how the so-called silica cavities
we have two different cavities that
we're looking at we have the few silica
cavity which is called the reference
cavity and then there'll be an
interference pattern which will be
generated at a modulated rate that will
oscillate periodically if this dark
matter scalar field exists and that will
change the effects of the
interferometric pattern so-called
correlation function and that's what
they're looking for so any strain which
is what ligo looks for it has a what's
called a strain sensitivity is what how
you account for its performance any
noise in the signal or any signal that
is caused by the dark matter will cause
an oscillation difference between the
signals in the reference cavity and the
signals inside the control signal
so the Dark Matter could induce a strain
which would be periodic unlike it
wouldn't be random like jittery noise of
thermal vibrations or agitation from
diurnal effects and things like that a
much longer time scales these would be
much shorter and ligo is well positioned
to measure so thermal noise is random it
doesn't repeat periodically the way that
it puted a dark matter signal could I
heard a ruckus could you describe the
Ruckus here's a graph of their
sensitivity which is really the ratio of
the signal to noise so the noise is
characterized here so now there's two
different ligo instruments two different
L-shaped interferometers one is in
Livingston Louisiana the other one's in
Hanford Washington the Hanford one is
far better for this particular type of
measurement has 10 times lower noise
across the wide spectral band and these
aren't like exotically extremely high or
extremely low frequencies these are
audio frequencies that you could hear
with your ears listen
you smell something and again what
they're looking for is to scan over
these different frequency terms and see
if it's possible for them to discern and
pick out of this Forest of lines that
comprise the noise background to see a
modulated in time signal consistent with
the Dark Matter Canon so here's their
ultimate limit we won't go through the
math there won't be any homework for
this uh you can read the paper if you're
interested in more of the details but
this is describing in this paper the
limits that they could get to with more
and more measurements and then
eventually a much quieter location with
lower Brownian motion from thermal noise
and lower vibrational noise from not
being located on the earth is the Lisa
Mission shown here a conceptual design
of it this could be launched in the next
decade or so and then this could lead to
a limit on the mass which is
characterized as all particle masses are
characterized by by their electron volt
energy divided by the speed of light
squared this is just relating their rest
mass energy E equals m c squared
dividing by c squared and getting the
equivalent Mass so the researchers found
they could use ligo laser frequency in
the reference cabin and the
interferometer itself to measure the
coupling of an ultra light scalar field
Dark Matter candidate to the standard
model particles these would be the
particles like the electrons in the
crystal inside the the cavities that
make up the actual cavities themselves
those are just made of ordinary matter
they're not making it out of exotic dark
matter or unobtaining them that's the
only reason they don't require any
special runs of the instrument they can
get this in real time as ligo is
catching the behavior of exploding black
holes of exploding supernovae perhaps
coalescing neutron stars and especially
its main most productive source of
discovery which are coalescing black
holes it can do this search for dark
matter at no cost in time sensitivity
error budget it can do that search at
the exact same time so it's very
efficient use of this exquisitely
sensitive and pricey instrument cost
about a billion dollars over its 20 or
so year lifetime so stay tuned we may
ultimately get the best possible data on
these ultralight Commander candidates
not from this ground base instrument but
from space the Lisa instrument
stay tuned for more information about
that and if you'd like to learn more
about ligo click this video here and
I'll see you in the next episode
foreign